par contre je ne descend jamais sans
qu'il ait mis la béquille parce que la
moto que tombait en même temps à 64 et
66 ans dominique et bernard sont fans de
motos goldwing leur particularité
une carrosserie imposante tout comme son
poids près de 400 kg pour ce modèle
jeunes mariés arpenter déjà les routes à
moto mais à la quarantaine ils ont
craqué pour ce modèle plus confort
désormais retraité il passe trois mois
de l'année a voyagé à bord de leur
bolide à deux roues au départ c'est vrai
qu'on a chez la moto pour notre plaisir
en dealant bond sortira le week-end à
deux et on a rencontré des copains qui
en avait qui nous ont dit viens club tu
vas voir
et puis on est allés au club on a une
ambiance formidable et depuis on est
toujours au club
on fait des sorties ou régionale
nationale ou dans vraiment locale entre
copains autriche espagne portugal france
le couple avale les kilomètres sans
jamais fatigué ou presque vous asseyez
dessus vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
tenir donc oui les longs trajets fini
par dormir mais la goldwing c'est avant
tout une passion commune puisque avec
ses deux grandes places assises la moto
est bien adaptée au couple
c'est nettement mieux qu'on peut
partager à deux que tout seul et des
copains écriront des fers femmes
même pas la moto rond et rend toujours
tout seul alors prévoir que la 2
prennent encore mieux il ya 22 ans le
couple participer à son premier
rassemblement international de goldwing
à vendôme
depuis ils n'ont pas raté une édition et
ce n'est pas près d'arriver